land west of Phoenix looked like this in
2002 now it's covered in buildings
Phoenix along with Las Vegas is
experiencing a stretch of triple digit
temperatures made worse by a heat Dome
record level temperatures shows no signs
of letting up unrelenting grip on the
country a lot of our cities have gotten
gotten bigger in the last 20 years
especially in the southwest here's what
happens when heat domes form above
cities and how Urban growth can make
that heat even more deadly
in Phoenix over 20 days in July have
been at or above 110 degrees and space
technology company maxar which has been
tracking the weather predicts the city
will hit at least 30 by the end of the
month in Las Vegas 16 days are predicted
to hit that high
that heat is driven in part by Urban
Development imagine a city as an island
with pavement roads surfaces glass and
steel buildings all of these surfaces
reflect sunlight and the heat energy
from the Sun back into the air around
these highly developed areas can see
midday temperatures that are 15 to 20
degrees warmer than surrounding
vegetated areas
we can see how these heat Islands formed
by looking back at Phoenix here it is 23
years ago
but after two decades of urban growth
the city has ballooned
back in 2000 Las Vegas looked like this
and now its City Limits have expanded
that expansion paralleled their economic
growth but more infrastructure turned up
the heat these are all places where heat
gets trapped right so in many of these
cities there's not a lot of breezes
there's not a lot of shade or trees and
so as a result heat can build up in
these Urban corridors it's sometimes
hard to grow trees in the west
especially in very arid places and the
native trees that grow there may not be
great at providing shade so you have a
lot of areas that get a lot a lot of sun
the other important thing about plants
and trees and vegetation and even grass
is they cycle moisture from the ground
into the air and help just a little bit
keep things cooler
that's driven Thompson Phoenix and Las
Vegas even higher and drove the creation
of these heat Islands but that's not the
only thing fueling the hot weather when
you have a heat Dome on top of this it
really intensifies the temperatures for
everyone living in this city
these domes are a natural weather
phenomenon and for most of July one has
been covering the Southwest a heat Dome
is a large ridge of high pressure high
in the atmosphere that basically traps a
lot of hot air underneath it and it can
last for a long time over time the Heat
Dome is basically reinforcing itself in
the sense that any moisture on the
ground or in the soil that may come up
into the atmosphere that perhaps could
cause some rain or rainstorms in the
afternoon that's going away the soils
are drying out the land is drying out
and so this hot air is making things
worse and worse the combination of a
heat Dome on top of a heat island means
that being outside can be even more
dangerous burn centers have reported
injuries to people who touch hot door
handles and walk Barefoot on scorched
pavement these are hot places right and
so there's often this feeling of well
it's always been hot here we're used to
it we can deal with it but I think that
mask some of the really significant
risks that are faced by people
experiencing homelessness by people who
are elderly people who work outside many
of these different groups that are that
are exposed and vulnerable
in cities already experiencing triple
digit temperatures the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration is
preparing officials for increasing heat
events everybody is very concerned about
about the future that with warming and
with climate change we expect more of
these events to happen and when these
events happen they're they're more
intense and scientists say the heat is
here to stay as Architects planners and
Engineers look to the Future they have
to take into account the effects of
climate change over time temperatures
that are rising storms and other things
that are happening as well so they're
taking these things into account with
new kinds of Technologies green roofs
that can absorb in cool buildings and
also just in a design and shape of
buildings that can provide more shade
and maybe just have a little bit of
resiliency toward a warming climate that
we're all facing in the future
[Music]